-This one is from Mike Rossmy.
"Hey, Jimmy, it's summer,
and that's the perfect time
for racing coolers that have
been turned into go-karts.
You should challenge
Dale Earnhardt Jr.
to a cooler scooter race."
Well, actually, I have
challenged Dale Earnhardt Jr.
to a cooler scooter race.
But he hasn't accepted.
That's right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
What?
-Challenge accepted, Jimmy.
-You want to do this?
We gonna do this?
We gonna do this now?
You want to do this right --
you want to this right now?
-Let's do this!
-Right here?
-Right here!
-Let's do this, buddy! Let's go!
-All right.
-Come on, man.
There's your cooler right there.
All right.
Here's how this race will work.
Dale and I will head out of
these doors.
We're gonna
say hello to Hashtag.
We're gonna make a left
to the elevator bank,
go around the shirtless
barbecuing uncle.
[ Laughter ]
Then head back down the hall.
But watch out for the punk kids
with Super Soakers.
[ Laughter ]
Then speed past the lifeguard,
in between two neighbors
fighting about their lawn.
Then drive back into the studio
to cross the finish line.
Dale, are you ready for this?
-Oh, man, I've never been more
ready in my life.
[ Laughter ]
-Higgins, count us down!
-Gentlemen, ready? Set!
Go!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
-Oh!
[ Ding ding ding ding ding ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
You crushed me.
This calls for --
[ Cheers and applause ]
A celebration.
Want a beverage?
-Yeah, absolutely.
-Cheers, buddy.
Dale Earnhardt Jr. right there,
the champ.